alors j'aimerais aborder ce soir un
thème qu'on a déjà commencé à aborder
celui des systèmes de pensée humains et
les implications des processus de prise
de décision quand on parle d'écologie et
d'environnement
alors j'ai eu la chance de grandir dans
une famille qui m'a sensibilisé à ces
jeunes à différentes sciences comme
l'écologie ou l'histoire de la vie sur
terre et j'ai pris conscience assez vite
de l'importance de répondre à l'urgence
climatique et en grandissant quand
j'étais ado je me disais dans tous les
cas l'homme est un animal rationnel donc
qui va résoudre le problème et on n'a
même pas besoin d'y penser au quotidien
jusqu'à ce que j'apprenne il ya un peu
plus de cinq ans l'histoire de l'île de
nauru et elle est assez intéressante et
j'aimerais vous la présenter alors nous
aurons c'est une île qui a été
découverte par des colons anglais à la
fin du xviiie siècle et c'est que
sentant plus tard qu on ya découvert des
gisements énormes de phosphate alors le
phosphate c'est un engrais naturel très
puissant qui étaient très demandés par
l'australie et la chine et de suite
après avoir découvert le langres et donc
en demi en 1906 vous avez pas mal de
mines qui ont commencé à venir sur place
raser des quelques parcelles de forêt et
prendre les plages pour commencer à
l'extraire et leur vendre et ça a
continué pendant des dizaines d'années
jusqu'à en 1968 l'année où lille a pris
son indépendance
alors cette année larmes les
scientifiques leur ont dit les gars
falloir faire un peu gaffe à votre
consommation de phosphate c'est votre
seule ressource naturelle et il va
falloir étaler sa consommation faire en
sorte de la préserver un petit peu le
phosphate et les forêts qui vont avec et
ceux qui ont décidé cette année là
c'était de continuer à miner le
phosphate toujours de plus en plus en
rasant les forêts mais cette fois en
gardant l'engrais pour eux et les
revenus pour eux et ça a très bien
marché pour eux à l'époque en trois ans
c'est devenu le deuxième pays le plus
riche au monde par habitant avec un
niveau de confort de vie presque
inégalée il s'achetait tous les voitures
des bateaux des climatiseurs tous que le
confort de vie de l'époque pouvait leur
offrir
et ça a duré jusqu'en 1990 quand les
mines on commençait à s'épuiser et en
2003 la dernière mine à la ferme et le
résultat
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nos roues est l'un
des pays les plus pauvres au monde ils
en sont réduits à devoir vendre des
passeports et faire de l'évasion fiscale
et sont en train même de négocier avec
l'australie pour pouvoir racheter des
terres est rebouché tous et tous pour
pouvoir faire pousser des armes à des
cultures on pourrait trouver cette
histoire un petit peu absurde mais faut
pas oublier qu'aujourd'hui on consomme
en termes de ressources l'équivalent de
deux planètes et ce qui est encore plus
étonnant c'est qu'on a développé des
solutions environnementales comme vous
le disait justement on a tous conscience
du problème
mais dans les faits on ne passe pas à
l'action
ou alors très peu et quand j'avais
découvert comment cette histoire je me
suis demandé mais pourquoi si un tel
gouffre entre la volonté d'agir une
action concrète et les scientifiques
certains scientifiques peuvent nous
laisse nous l'expliqué par la façon dont
l'homme réfléchi et les mécanismes de
prise de décision alors si on laissait
de simplifier un petit peu ces
mécanismes l'homme va répondre et va
réagir face à un danger ou face à un
intérêt il ya deux systèmes de
mécanismes qui viennent de rentrer en
jeu
vous avez le système émotionnelle qui
est très puissant et il avait le système
rationnel qui l'est beaucoup moins
et on va prendre un exemple que vous
connaissez tous ici pour illustrer la
différence d'efficacité entre les deux
systèmes
la procrastination quand on va faire un
mémoire ou une thèse on part tous du
concept qu'on va essayer dé talent et le
travail sur la durée qu'on va travailler
un petit peu chaque mois parce que ça va
être plus agréable et plus facile à
faire
c'est ce que je m'étais dit moi quand
j'avais voulu fermer mon mémoire à
l'époque ça que le premier mois je me
suis dit j'y pensais même pas deuxième
moi je me dis qu'il y avait le temps
donc le travail s'accumuler sur la fin
de l'année et au bout de quelques mois
il ya un mécanisme rationnelle qui
rentré en jeu la culpabilité alors la
culpabilité c'est un petit peu marcher
dans le sens où j'ai commencé à
déterminer quels quel ouvrage je vais
lire pour m'inspirer pour mon mémoire
j'ai commencé à faire la préface et ça a
suffi pour calmer mon sentiment de
culpabilité pendant plusieurs mois
jusqu'à ce que j'approche de la fin de
l'année où la culpabilité rationnelle
s'est transformé en stress émotionnel et
là ça a très bien marché j'ai fini mon
et morts en cinq jours
j'ai très mal fait j'ai une pas une très
bonne note mais je les fais et c'est là
que c'est intéressant
le système est moche elle est beaucoup
plus puissant que le stand rationnelle
parce qu'ils se basent sur des
mécanismes totalement différent le
système rationnel se base sur une
représentation mentale d'un danger ou
d'un intérêt alors que le système
émotionnel lui va se baser sur des
neurotransmetteurs très puissant que mon
évolution comme c'est les autres animaux
m'a poussé à développer pour pouvoir
réagir face à ces dangers intérêts dans
le cas du danger c'est l'adrénaline on
connaît tous
c'est le sentiment de stress par exemple
je me promène dans la forêt et je tombe
sur un ours ma réaction biologique
standard est normal ça va être de fuir
je me barre en courant en aucun cas je
vais rester tranquillement en train de
me dire que je vais vaquer à mes
occupations pour m'en charger plus tard
ou encore pire que je vais laisser le
problème aux futures générations
c'est impossible et dans le cas de
l'environnement comme le danger n'est
pas immédiat je me trouve des excuses je
me dis que je le ferai plus tard je
procrastine parce que qu'on ait perdu
50% des du phytoplancton les forêts
tropicales depuis 1950
je peux pas l'imaginer je peux même pas
me représenter que le réchauffement
climatique dérèglement climatique va
entraîner des centaines de millions de
migration dans le monde entier que 30%
des pays-bas au que matane va finir sous
le niveau de l'eau tout ça je peux je
peux pas le sentir je peux pas
l'appréhender et quand je pourrai sentir
le danger c'est qu il sera déjà trop
tard
donc si on récapitule le système de
pensée rationnelle et trop peu efficace
je peux pas compter sur le stress
émotionnel donc pour résoudre le
problème environnemental
il faudrait se baser sur l'intérêt
émotionnelle comme pour le danger ils se
basent sur des neurotransmetteurs très
puissant donc là c'est la dopamine et
l'endorphine on connaît sous forme de
plaisir ou bien être et c'est un
mécanisme qui rentrent en jeu quand je
vais avoir de la reconnaissance sociale
de l'appartenance à un groupe quand je
vais avoir un retour immédiat personnel
de la récompense un exemple on connaît
tous ici c'est les réseaux sociaux
quand j'ai un like quand j'ai un
commentaire sur facebook j'ai un petit
pic des dopamine
du coup on passe énormément de temps sur
les réseaux sociaux plus qu'à penser à
la reforestation par exemple et on
pourrait utiliser ses mécanismes là et
les appliquer à l'écologie ce que
malheureusement aujourd'hui
l'écologie c'est pas fun c'est pas
valorisé socialement il n'y a pas de
récompense et l'impact il est
impersonnelle il est pas il n'est pas
direct et vous avez d'autres secteurs
qui utilisent et qui s'inspire justement
de ce cerveau et des ces mécanismes
émotionnelle pour développer une
activité
c'est le cas de l'éducation l'éducation
aujourd'hui utilisent de plus en plus
les mécanismes des jeux vidéo pour faire
de l'éducation qui est parfois perçue
comme une contrainte quelque chose de
beaucoup plus fun je peux prendre
exemple des écoles suédoise où les
enfants apprennent avec des jeux vidéo
ludique ou encore de l'école 42 cas une
école informatique a été sacrée
meilleure école d'informatique au monde
dans laquelle n'y a pas de professeurs
les étudiants viennent et apprennent
d'eux mêmes et ils ont un système de
rang de badges de scor et de classement
qui va rendre l'éducation beaucoup plus
ludique beaucoup plus personnel et les
étudiants ils vont même le week-end pour
apprendre
on pourrait très bien imaginer de
reprendre les mécanismes des jeux vidéo
et les applique à l'écologie un système
de rands système de récompense de badge
par exemple si un milliardaire pouvait
passer le premier architecte de
l'humanité sur sa page wikipédia
peut-être qu'ils se mettraient à léguer
sa fortune pour les projets de
reboisement et on peut très bien aussi
jouer sur les mécanismes des réseaux
sociaux des systèmes de récompenses et
on a d'ailleurs un exemple qui prouve
que rapprocher les solutions
environnementales des incitations
émotionnel marche très bien
c'est cette personne là nous l'a prouvé
quand il a lancé le ps l'a donc pour
ceux qui connaissent pas l unsc c'est le
fondateur de space x de hyper loupé de
solarcity et de tesla donc tesla se
différencie des autres marchands voiture
électrique parce qu'un peu plus de dix
ans quand tout le monde essayait de
faire les voitures électriques peu
coûteuse mais du coup qui était pas sexy
qui était pas autonome et qui coûtait
quand même beaucoup plus cher une
voiture standard il a décidé de faire
une voiture électrique très coûteuse
mais très sexy et qui se conduit presque
toute seule elle passée de 1 à 100
km/heure en l'espace de quelques
secondes
donc beaucoup de gens en ont parlé et
les influenceurs ont voulu acheter cette
voiture là et ont commencé à valoriser à
communiquer sur le fait qu'ils avaient
une tesla donc il n'a pas inventé la
voiture électrique ça fait plus de cent
ans on a des voitures électriques
mais ce qu'il a fait c'est créer le
marché en rapprochant la voiture
électrique des attentes émotionnel il
est passé de ça à ça et tesla s'est pas
le seul exemple qu'on peut prendre on a
aussi des bornes de recyclage dans
lequel on va pouvoir mettre une canette
ou un gobelet et ça nous donnaient des
cadeaux des récompenses directement et
on voit que les gens recyclent bien plus
parce que ça devient fun parce que ça
devient récompensés on a un autre
exemple qui me plaît pas mal c'est un
escalier qui joue de la musique quand je
monte les marches et ce qu'ils ont ce
qu'on a remarqué c'est que les gens
prennent prenez les escaliers quasiment
à chaque fois au lieu de prendre
l'ascenseur ou de prendre l'escalator
donc en réussissant à rapprocher en tout
cas la solution des mécanismes humains
des mécanismes émotionnel on parvient à
développer les solutions
environnementales et c'est peut-être là
une des clés pour résoudre la crise
aujourd'hui la crise environnementale
qui qui se prépare inquiète chacun peut
commencer
c'est pas simplement de développer des
solutions en essayant de sensibiliser le
public
il ferait peut-être en plus innover et
continuer un rapproché les solutions
existantes des attentes du public les
attentes des gens ceci sera toujours
plus facile de rapprocher l'écologie de
la société que de rapprocher la société
de l'écologie merci à tous
[Applaudissements]